you've put up a boundary whether it's
with an X whether it's with a parent
whether it's with a grandparent whether
it's with whoever
number one expect that people are going
to try to test that boundary and see if
it's going to hold they're going to run
up against it they're going to throw
things over they're going to send notes
however they're going to try to find out
is this boundary gonna hold
number two expect other people to be
upset that that boundary exists because
that boundary disrupts not just the
relationship between you and the person
you're putting the boundary up but it it
affects other people siblings friend
groups uh Church groups everybody in
between
the third thing is there may come a
season when that boundary doesn't serve
you anymore and we're ready to move on
but for right now it's gonna stay or
whatever or I'm gonna give you a number
four I'm gonna give you an ultimatum
these things have to happen or this
boundary goes up